so i'm doubt just doing my job doing
other things and making announcements
like we do and the media
starts badgering me with these slogans
about gay and i'm thinking to myself
okay
um this isn't my first rodeo i know what
they're doing they create narratives and
then they try to run with these
narratives so i know they're lying i
don't know how they're lying but i just
know they are so i ask myself what is
going on with this why are they doing
this and then i see and i'm like you've
got to be kidding me
i moved to this great state six months
ago okay and i gotta tell you as i
opened with you guys have done it right
and it's it's you and it's you and it's
you and it's you and it's everyone in
this room and it's that florida man knew
something that the rest of us had
forgotten or maybe we never knew
and i promise you that i am here to keep
florida florida and i'm also here to
support this guy ladies and gentlemen
governor ron desantis everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
good evening orlando
[Applause]
and again welcome to the state of
florida and uh thank you so if you come
from california we all we do have
reservations when people come
but you're doing it right and so i
really believe a lot of the people that
have come in the last couple years i
think they're making the state more red
not less red so yes
i don't know if you heard right at the
beginning how many of you guys are new
floridians last year or two
wow i mean look at that that is a
beautiful thing i feel i can either ask
you questions or we could just let
people say nice things to you for the
next 40 minutes
what do you think we should do here well
look i think it's your show i'm just
here for the ride but we're excited to
be here and congratulations on the book
man thank you thank you all right
all right so
first off we have to start with the
obvious one
gay
[Applause]
he didn't even flinch
[Music]
nothing nothing you just i thought that
in this state we can't say gay there's
people outside they're freaking out
they've got bull horns man
what is i mean
did you choose this fight or do you feel
like they they just brought it to you
and you just punched back
no yeah look i mean look i'm i'm
punching back it was interesting when
that bill was going through the when the
legislature's in session they're there
for 60 days
and there's a lot of stuff that's going
on i'm not following every little
committee hearing or anything i mean
i've got dozens of priorities and i've
got folks working on so i'm doubt just
doing my job doing other things and
making announcements like we do and the
media
starts badgering me with these slogans
about gay and i'm thinking to myself
okay
this isn't my first rodeo i know what
they're doing they create narratives and
then they try to run with these
narratives so i know they're lying i
don't know how they're lying but i just
know they are so i ask myself what is
going on with this why are they doing
this and then i see and i'm like you've
got to be kidding me are they honestly
going to make this the hill to die on
and so even though it was not
necessarily legislation that i had
authored initially
i started fighting back against them
because they were just lying to people
and it's offensive when they're lying
and
and so we start fighting back and i
would literally have these reporters i'd
say okay where does it say that in the
bill okay it doesn't say that in the
bill what does it say oh okay so you
know and so it was it was it was good we
were fighting back and then you had this
situation where you had the corporations
mostly disney
deciding to get involved and i think
people look at that they're like first
of all i don't know why they got
involved in this it was a huge mistake
for them they think they've lost 60
billion in market cap since they got
involved but what what the left is doing
though it's honestly smart for them
they know that if people knew
that
if they were running for election on
gender ideology for kindergarten first
graders that would not fly with the
voters okay
parents just don't want that for these
young kids and a lot of the elderly in
florida don't even know what the hell
you're talking about so it's not it's
not good and they know they can't win
elections on that so i think what they
what they try to do which is smart they
say okay if we could subcontract out our
leftism to a corporation pressure the
corporation to come on our side then
maybe they can get these elected
officials to cave and you know what it's
not a dumb strategy because there have
been a lot of republican governors that
have caved to corporate pressure you've
had republican governors veto bills just
to protect women's athletics and women's
sports because some of the businesses
got upset so i understood why they were
doing it i thought it was a mistake for
disney to get involved and i told them
you shouldn't get involved it's not
going to work out well for you so they
kind of got involved
i i don't know if you heard what donald
duck's been up to
but
no but the thing is is
is you know they're going to go out and
i honestly i think it's ridiculous when
these corporations do all this stuff but
you're free to do it but when they're
lying and they're accepting these phony
narratives just think what happened last
year when georgia did their election
integrity law you had a massive hysteria
by corporate media by the left by uh
twitter and all this stuff you had delta
airlines you had coca-cola demagogue the
bill they equated it to jim crow you had
major league baseball move the all-star
game out of atlanta and so we've now had
our first election in georgia
earlier or last month under the new law
record voter turnout and so
they were lying about the georgia bill
anyone who read it would know and so i
think when they're accepting these false
narratives especially if it's about
people in my state that are in the
legislature or whatever we have a
responsibility uh to fight back but i
think disney took it one step further
when they put out this incredible
statement after they already did all
their virtue signaling after we signed
the bill saying this was somehow a
violation of human rights and that they
would work to see that parents rights
and education were repealed through the
legislature and i'm just thinking to
myself
you know i took an oath to support the
laws and constitution of the u.s and the
state of florida i did not
take an oath
to subcontract out my leadership to a
corporation based in burbank california
they don't run this state
and so
but again they are free to do that i
think for a publicly traded corporation
i think it's stupid and so i think that
you're gonna have a situation all right
butt out nobody wants to hear from you
nobody wants to hear from you get out of
here
[Applause]
got plenty of friends for you across the
street my man
so they they get in they're going to
commit themselves to this really
ridiculous uh course of action
and they're free to do that it's not
smart as a publicly trade but you are
free to do that
but they are not
free to force all of us to subsidize
their activism and that's what they were
doing
they have their own government or they
did have their own government right here
they're exempt from laws they get
massive tax breaks and so you know if
their company is committed to that view
of what's appropriate for children and
parents uh as the state we just can't
have a partnership with that and so
we're out and that's why we took action
to dissolve their own government
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell